let's go next to Manuel from Florida
Welcome to the program my friend
hello David hello it has been a long
time but it's nice to speak to you again
thank you uh let's see I've been
thinking about
sort of the direction of
what is like popular sentiment in
America and it feels like the next
generation is overwhelmingly more
liberal more Progressive
um I I can't I can't cite that right now
I don't have it off the top of my head
you are right generally speaking each
successively younger generation is more
Progressive than the previous for now
that continues to hold true
yeah and but there's also like a lot of
the things that the conservative
side of the spectrum like hold on to are
really
old like traditions right that they go
back a long time yes so it you'll always
have that that in some capacity you know
whether it's small or big on that side
of the spectrum
but do you think
they would ever be
I don't know like I don't see it ever
going away but do you think it'll come
back like do you think for example
Christian nationalism that it'll truly
grow to be popular or will it always
stay a kind of this small Niche I don't
think any prediction I could make about
that would be worth a penny I mean
really humans are so terrible at making
these types of predictions and this is
why when Trump was using the line during
his 2020 I think it was in 2020 he would
say we will never be a socialist country
maybe we will I don't know I mean it
doesn't seem to be going in that
direction right now but how can we say
the U.S will never be a socialist
country 500 years a thousand years if
the U.S is still around maybe it will be
a socialist country that being said
right now there's no socialists in power
so it's not going to happen anytime soon
so I I would be very hesitant to make
any Maybe Christian nationalism will
maybe we will be a CR a fully legal
Christian theocracy at some point in
time I don't know I I would hesitate to
make any of these never Contra uh
predictions
yeah no I feel that I mean this is you
know kind of a what a baptism but it I
don't know I was just thinking about it
because you see a lot of people say that
Christian nationalism is a threat so I
wonder like is it a threat in so far as
it could become popular or is it just a
threat insofar as this small group of
people can be very dangerous I think it
depends on who you ask and exactly where
and what year it is but I I think it's
fair to say that Christian nationalism
is a threat in the sense that it
threatens the America that the founding
fathers created that's it's a threat in
that sense and then is it a practical
and imminent threat well there is a
group that if they took power would make
Christian theocracy a reality right now
they thankfully don't have that power
but they are certainly a threat in that
they want more power so it's just about
better defining what we mean by threat
if that makes sense
no yeah that does make sense
yeah I just wanted to hear what your
thoughts were on on that so I appreciate
it again well I appreciate the call very
much things are okay in Florida
oh things are great because the
weather's epic right now we're looking
at like 70 degree weather good like I'm
in California so yeah well I'm hoping to
get down soon and reschedule this
appearance with Patrick Bet David that I
was supposed to do and uh yeah before
you know it I might be back in Florida
okay awesome yeah I have a Cuban
sandwich right here heavy white a Cuban
sandwich Cuban oh all right yeah well
we'll talk about that let's talk about
the pork later all right okay Manuel
thank you very much for the call
appreciate it that does it for today
we're done for the day with live calls
appreciate everyone I was able to speak
to and we will take live calls again